pretty jaw-dropping story came out of
the judiciary over the past couple days
the the alliance defending freedom filed
a lawsuit i filed suit in february
against the connecticut
inter-scholastic athletic conference
on behalf of three girls and these girls
are student athletes and the lawsuit
it's i think it's a pretty legitimate
gripe the
girls want to be able to compete in
girls sports
against other girls it
doesn't sound that radical to me and yet
because of our new gender ideology
that the radical left is forcing on the
country the girls were forced to compete
against boys albeit boys who
pretended that they were girls and guess
what happened i think you
probably won't be surprised to find out
the boys tended to win because boys and
girls are different
and boys physically are stronger than
girls and so obviously that's how it
turns out
now they're filing this suit and the
judge in the case
the very beginning he said okay we'll
hear out the case but before we begin
you're not allowed to refer to the boys
who are
saying that they're girls as boys you
have to refer to them as girls
which means from the beginning of the
case the judge is already saying
that the transgender activists are
correct from the beginning of the case
he's already come to his conclusion very
complicated issue
pretty uh pretty much a head scratcher
luckily
to uh join us now and help us make some
sense of it
is one of the great writers on this
issue in the country
madeleine kearns the william f buckley
fellow
in political journalism at the national
review
institute maddie has written for the
wall street journal daily telegraph
daily mail the scotsman the catholic
herald heterodox academy everywhere she
is
all over the place maddie thank you for
coming on
thanks for having michael always a
pleasure so
i i need you to help me make sense of
this because
maybe i'm a little bit slow maybe i'm
just missing something
but if if the judge in this case is
saying at the very
outset that everybody including the
the plaintiffs and the attorneys have to
refer to the boys
as girls then isn't he basically saying
that
he's throwing out the complaint in the
first place
i mean pretty much which is why the
alliance defending freedom has asked by
that he would choose himself
the problem is there's a disagreement
about what the point this case is
so the uh plaintiffs so the
three high school girls see it as you
see it and as i see it to do with
biological sex the reality is
no matter what you call these boys they
are still boys they are so male
and they do have innate advantages
that's the point the point for us
is sex and the point of the argument is
in relation to title nine
which spells out protections for women
and girls on the basis
of sex that's the wording what the the
left doing what the
defendants are doing in this case and
now the judge as well
is conflating sex with this gender
identity
this theory that actually they're kind
of the same thing and
uh one overrate the other and it and
really it's very offensive
to call transgender girls and murder
promise um
anything but transgender girls or girls
and so calling them males is too
offensive and so we we can't really
proceed if you can't go bored of that of
course as you point out
that means it's it's kind of a case
closed but they you know they
they see it a different way they think
that they can play these little
rhetorical flight of hands and nobody
goes well that's
that's the whole problem i guess i mean
if you really zoomed out
from the broader perspective of how
we've gotten to this point
it would seem that one of the culprits
is political correctness right
calling things as they are not
so pretending that just because you call
a boy a girl
then all of a sudden the boy really is a
girl but of course
we know that isn't the case i want to
focus in a little bit
on on two words that you just said title
nine title nine as i understand it
among other things establishes girls
sports at schools
and that's so that there's not just you
know discrimination on the basis of sex
the left
has made a big issue out of that phrase
on the basis of sex
ruth bader ginsburg made a career out of
that phrase on the basis of sex and yet
now
if if the left is going to redefine sex
away from your actual biological sex
into your kind of perceived
gender identity then doesn't that
completely
undermine title ix in other words if
title ix
among other things sets up girls sports
and then you redefine sex to not mean
sex
and and so boys can now compete against
girls
doesn't that actually abolish girls
sports doesn't that actually abolish
title ix itself yeah of course it does
but of course the way that they get
around this
is by claiming that the transgender
girls i.e the boys do you think they're
girls
are girls and so actually what's
interesting in this particular case is
that both sides
are arguing that there's been an
affirmative violation of title
ix i.e both sides argue that girls
have been harmed by uh by
either you know the law or or a pushback
against law so
um so it's kind of extraordinary you
know we're really we really are arguing
about
whether black is black and white is
white here i mean it's it it's
but this is this is why the the let's do
this and and
and there's lots of people have written
on this from orwell to sort of the late
rogers christian about how the left
sometimes think that
that by changing language you can in
some way
change metaphysical reality i mean
it's a certain degree of magical
thinking that i don't know how rational
people buy into it
but that is what we're seeing in this
case well the left has talked about this
for even longer than all that you know i
mean this has been a strategy
uh used by left-wing theorists all the
way back to antonio gramsci the italian
communist party leader
who and up through various academic
thinkers and into the 20th century
who say that by changing language we can
actually change our political reality
and another way they do it is
when you change the language you no
longer have to fight the political
battles so in this case if if the
argument is that
they want to let boys who identify as
girls who who think that they're girls
or wannabe girls
play in the girls sports we could just
pass a law saying that couldn't we you
could
persuade your fellow citizens pass a law
and then that's all fine
but they know that that law would get
vetoed nobody would actually vote for
that
and so they try to they try to avoid it
from the very beginning
we saw this in another issue actually
just uh maybe
10 years ago and building up through the
last few years which is
the issue of same-sex marriage you know
the question of same-sex marriage was
always
what is a marriage you know does sexual
difference
play some role in marriage and then the
way the left won that battle
is they redefined marriage from the very
beginning
and they said no marriage is just a
relationship between two individuals
regardless of sex
so then the question became who has the
right to get married
and you know if the if the question
becomes who has the right to get married
then they've already won that because we
all want everybody to have
rights it's this very subtle game of
language because
the actual debate on the marriage
question was what
is a marriage and i guess the actual
question here is
what is a girl maddie you've been
following this very closely
for a long time i can't say that i'm
very encouraged by what this
judge is saying here i mean are are we
just headed
inevitably for a world in which the
judges and a bunch of rogue lawyers
redefine sex and forces transgender
ideology on us
well i think we are going to see like
it's going to become a big
fight and we're already we're awaiting
actually
as we speak another case uh in the
supreme court this time
uh harris funeral homes which is another
alliance defending freedom
case which should really they should be
coming out with a decision
on that uh fairly soon um and that will
set
precedent um a legal president which
which if it goes
their way the act this way would be very
very hard to undo but you're absolutely
right in the sense that it fundamentally
comes down to this
ontological argument what is a woman
versus this rhetorical argument
what is polite to say essentially um
it's very problematic though because of
course i sometimes think that
conservatives don't do enough to
to kind of make the the rhetorical point
case themselves i mean
what we're talking about here is never
mind offending these these boys who who
want to compete against girls i mean it
must be so humiliating
and excruciatingly painful to be
excluded from
from your sport to watch people who you
know
to to be male just dominate you and and
in sports and then when you have legal
counsel
representing your case to be told to to
say something that you believe to be a
lie or that they have to say something
that you will
be alive um you know i mean i think
there is a
there's a kind of an emotional side of
it on on the women's side as well which
i think is just um
which was very real and and often looked
over
now those women are always getting
looked over aren't they i mean that that
is the issue that you don't hear about
here
is first of all it's humiliating because
you you don't get to
you know seriously compete in your own
sports
but there's a real hard money side of
this too you could lose out on
scholarships
you could lose out on awards and on
being recruited for
for different teams my friend matt walsh
always asks this question when this
transgenderism issue comes up and the
question is very simple it's
what is a woman and the left doesn't
seem to give an
answer to that they they they kind of
scoff at the question
but they don't seem able to answer it
maddie can you give an answer you've got
a a number of years expertise on being a
woman what is a woman
a woman is a person who is all for the
female sex
and we have various we have various
biological markers which we use
to define that which are absolutely
self-evident at birth
yeah you know i mean you go to the
chromosomes if we go to hormones and
reproductive organs but we're just
stating obviously like
we know i mean everybody knows what a
woman is
in very very very rare cases there can
be a level of
ambiguity to be discussed between
families and doctors that is a
completely separate issue and they know
that
um this transgender thing is just is
just
as you say michael you can't define it
there's no definition
yeah it's just anybody who says that
they are you know maddie and our in our
remaining
minute or two here do you have any sense
of the court
gossip because i i followed this case as
well the harris funeral home case
which is not about title ix as i
understand it it's about title vii
it's about whether you can have an
employer say that a a man has to wear
the uniform that a man wears and a
a woman has to wear the uniform that a
woman wears and even if the man thinks
he's a woman
or vice versa uh how is this case gonna
go i've been told that one of the great
hallmarks of the trump presidency
is that we've gotten these conservative
or originalist judges
uh are are we going to have a proper
definition of sex vindicated or or some
of these josh's
judges going to go squishy well the
difficulty with the harrah's case is
it's actually
it's quite complicated because as you
point out part of it's to do with this
dress code thing
and then part of it is also to do with
the definition of sex
it wasn't that encouraging in the oral
arguments to be parallel it's not as
encouraging i thought it would be based
on that we have a conservative court
you know gorsuch said a few things which
were kind of suggesting he was he was
sympathizing more than i thought he
should with the other side
we'll have to wait and see it does look
like um
it's going to be one of those cases
that's going to be so explosive either
way it wouldn't
surprise me if they waited till the very
last moment of the term just to
drop that bomb um but i i really i
really wish i wish i could give you a
firmer answer
i just don't know that's fair enough i
wanted to get some gossip out of you
matty you're unlike so many other
political observers
who emphatically make predictions then
they all turn out to be wrong but then
they keep going on and making
predictions
instead you are just giving a more
cautious and
probably reliable analysis this is a
real fear you know if
if gorsuch goes squishy on this that's
going to have serious ramifications
for the credibility of originalism for
the credibility of conservative
jurisprudence
we would be in a very very uh tense
situation if that were to occur but i
guess we'll just have to wait and see
matty thank you so much for being here
madeline kearns the william f buckley
fellow in political journalism
at the national review institute uh
please go and read her stuff it's really
really great
maddie thank you for being here thanks
for having me
[Music]
you